.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT BIDEN WAS GOING TO BE
HONORING THE LIFE OF DR. MARTIN
LUTHER KING JR., THE PRESIDENT
WHO PREACHES UNITY, USING THE
OCCASION TO ATTACK HIS
REPUBLICAN CRITICS.
>> TALK ABOUT BIG SPENDING
DEMOCRATS AGAIN?
GUESS WHAT.
I REDUCED THE DEFICIT LAST YEAR
$350 BILLION.
BUT SO WHAT.
THESE GUYS ARE FISCALLY
DEMENTED, I THINK.
>> JOE BIDEN SOUNDS UTTERLY
RIDICULOUS.
HE WANTS TO KEEP THE ITEMS THAT
HE'S RATCHETED UP SPENDING IN,
HE WANTS TO KEEP THEM, AS
OPPOSED TO EXAMINING THINGS AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL, TO GET OUR
DEBT AND INFLATION UNDER
CONTROL.
>> Dana: AND THE PRESIDENT
TURNING HEADS WITH THESE
COMMENTS ABOUT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT AND CAR INSURANCE.
>> I AM GOING TO GET ASSAULT
WEAPONS BANNED.
I DID IT ONCE.
I'M GOING TO DO IT AGAIN.
I LOVE MY RIGHT WING FRIENDS,
TALK ABOUT THE TREE OF LIBERTY
IS WATER IN THE BLOOD OF
PATRIOTS.
IF YOU NEED TO WORK TAKING ON
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, YOU NEED
SOME F-15s.
YOU DON'T NEED AN AR-15.
I'M SERIOUS.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU LIVE IN ONE
OF THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS, YOU HAVE
THE EXACT SAME CAR I HAVE IN THE
OTHER NEIGHBORHOOD, YOU PAY MORE
INSURANCE.
NO BASIS FOR IT.
NONE AT ALL, OTHER THAN YOU'RE
BLACK AND I'M WHITE.
>> Jeanine: OH, MY.
>> Dana: UNITY, GREG?
>> Greg: I SWORE WHEN HE BECAME
PRESIDENT WE WOULDN'T BECOME
LIKE THEM, LIKE THE TRUMP
DERANGEMENT SYNDROME, BUT BIDEN
I REFUSE TO SEE HIM AS EVIL OR
INHERENTLY BAD, BUT HE IS
PATHETIC IN THE SENSE THAT HE
WAS ALWAYS KIND OF KNOWN FOR
BEING -- HAVING MANNERS AND
CLASS AND CONGENIAL, BUT HE
THERE'S A TRIBUTE TO MLK, AND HE
USES IT TO DEMONIZE A PARTY.
WHAT IS THIS?
IS THIS THE JOE BIDEN EVERYBODY
THOUGHT THEY KNEW?
OF COURSE NOT.
THAT ONE IS DEAD.
THIS ISN'T EVEN A THINKING
SELF-AWARE INDIVIDUAL AT THIS
POINT.
HERE'S JOY REED WITH AN
ARTIFICIAL HIP, WILL SAY OR DO
ANYTHING.
HE DOESN'T CARE.
THE LINE HE ALWAYS USES, SO
TIRED, ABOUT THE F-15.
YOU KNOW, WHEN HE SAYS, YOU
KNOW, YOU CAN'T FIGHT THE
GOVERNMENT UNLESS YOU HAVE AN
F-15.
HE'S LIKE THAT OBNOXIOUS STUPID
CHILD AT A ZOO, BANGING ON THE
WINDOW OF A LION ENCLOSURE AND
SAYING, AHA, YOU CAN'T GET ME.
THAT'S LITERALLY THE LEVEL OF
HIS INFANTTILE DISCOURSE.
HE CLAIMED A QANON SHAM MAN
THREATENED OUR DEMOCRACY.
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS, YOU
DOPE BRAIN, THAT OUR DEMOCRACY
IS IN PERIL.
HE'S ABSOLUTELY LOST HIS MIND.
AGAIN, I'M NOT LOSING MY MIND
OVER THIS.
IT'S NOT DERANGEMENT SYNDROME.
THIS IS SIMPLY WATCHING THE
DECLINE OF AN INDIVIDUAL.
YOU CAN SAY THIS.
YOU CAN THAT HE'S LOST HIS MIND
NOW, BECAUSE THERE'S NOTHING
WORSE THAN SOMEBODY CALLING YOU
A RACIST IN THIS SOCIETY.
SO HE'S EXTENDING THAT
PLATFORM, THAT BAR, SOUTHEAST,
SO WHEN YOU SAY HE'S SEEN NILE
OR IDIOTIC, THAT'S NOT CLOSE TO
BEING A RACIST, BECAUSE BEING
DEMENTED IS OUT OF YOUR CONTROL,
BUT WHEN SOMEBODY CALLS YOU A
RACIST THAT'S AN ATTACK ON YOUR
MORAL BEING.
I GUESS ALL ATTACKS ARE OFF AT
THIS POINT.
>> Dana: I WANTED EVERYBODY TO
KNOW, YOU HAVE TO STICK AROUND
FOR MY "ONE MORE THING" BECAUSE
THERE'S A DEEP TEASE.
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT IT IS,
BUT YOU JUST --
>> Greg: HOPE IT DOESN'T INVOLVE
KILMEADE.
>> Dana: IF YOU CAN PLAY THE
CALL ABOUT THE IRS, AND GET
JUDGE JEANINE TO RESPOND.
>> ALL THE IRS AGENTS WE HAVE,
BECAUSE THEY FIRED A LOT OF
THEM, AND LIEUTENANT OF -- A LOT
OF THEM RETIRING.
WHO NEEDS SERIOUS AGENTS TO KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND NOT
DOING?
THE BILLIONAIRES, THE
MULTI-MULTIMILLIONAIRES.
THIS ONE BILL ALONE WILL ADD
$114 BILLION TO THE DEFICIT.
THEY DIDN'T SAY IF ELECTED THE
PLAN IS TO MAKE INFLATION WORSE.
>> Dana: THE REASON THEY NEED
THE IRS AGENTS, IT GOES TO GREEN
SUBSIDIES.
>> Jeanine: FOUR THINGS TO
COMMENT ON FROM THE SPEECH.
NUMBER ONE, HE'S ONE OF THE MOST
DECISIVE PRESIDENTS IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS TAKEN ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AS OPPOSED TO
TAKING ON PEOPLE OF A FOREIGN
COUNTRY WHO WANT AMERICANS TO
DIE, ISRAEL TO DIE, ALL THAT
STUFF.
NUMBER TWO, HE IS SOMEONE WHO IS
TAKING ALL THIS CREDIT, CALLING
US CRAZY ABOUT THE ECONOMY, WHEN
THE TRUTH IS HE RAN THE DEFICIT
UP TO A WORLD RECORD OF
$2.5 TRILLION IN 2021.
THEN IN 2022, BORROWED ANOTHER
$1.5 TRILLION, THE HIGHEST EVER.
HE'S THE MOST FINANCIALLY
RECKLESS PRESIDENT WE'VE EVER
HAD.
YOU KNOW, IT'S LIKE AN ALCOHOLIC
BRAGGING, LOOK, I WENT FROM
EIGHT DRINKS TO SIX DRINKS.
YOU KNOW, THINGS ARE REALLY GOOD
NOW.
THEN THE OTHER THING, HIS
COMMENT ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THEY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO SHOOT THEM IN
THE LEG.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO SHOOT.
LOOK, COPS ARE TRAINED TO SHOOT
CENTER MASS WHEN THEY ARE
RESISTING DEADLY PHYSICAL FORCE.
IT'S NOT LIKE A WESTERN, WHERE
YOU'VE GOT SOME GUY WHO'S GOING
TO SHOOT THE GUN OUT OF YOUR
HAND.
OKAY?
UNLESS YOU GOT A SNIPER, YOU GO
FOR CENTER MASS.
THAT SHOWS HE'S TOTALLY
DISCONNECTED.
FINALLY THIS IDEA OF THE
ILLINOIS GOVERNOR AND THE
ASSAULT WEAPONS, ALL THAT, FIRST
OF ALL, THE ASSAULT WEAPON BAN
IN '93, THE RESULTS OF IT ARE
VERY UNCLEAR.
HE SAYS HE WANTS TO DO IT AGAIN.
FINE.
THE ILLINOIS GOVERNOR IS TELLING
HIS SHERIFFS THEY WON'T HAVE
THEIR JOB IF THEY DON'T ENFORCE
THE ASSAULT WEAPON BAN IN
ILLINOIS.
HE CAN'T TAKE THEIR JOBS AWAY
FROM THEM, BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
ELECTED.
>> Dana: GERALDO, DOESN'T
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAVE TO MAKE A
DECISION TO ANNOUNCE HE'S
RUNNING FOR ELECTION, THE
CONGENIAL PRESIDENT THAT SAYS
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
ANYTHING OR THE DECISIVE ONE
WHERE HE DEFAULTS TO IN THESE
SPEECHES?
>> Geraldo: YOU'RE MUCH MORE OF
AN EXPERT ON POLITICS THAN I AM.
>> Dana: NOT ON THIS ONE.
I DON'T KNOW.
>> Geraldo: IT'S A STONER STREAM
OF CONSCIOUSNESS, THAT SPEECH.
IT WAS DISCONNECTED.
I LIKE THE GUY.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHERE HE WAS GOING
WITH THE -- THE AR-15s.
WHAT DOES HAVE THAT TO DO WITH
THE 87,000 IRS AGENTS.
IT JUST SEEMED A WHOLE MISHMOSH.
IT SEEMED OMINOUSLY TO SPEAK OF
THE DIVISION, YOU MENTIONED,
JUDGE.
YOU KNOW, DOES HE WANT TWO
SIDES?
IF I MAY, WITH CONSIDERABLE
EXPERIENCE IN WAR, I JUST WANT
TO GIVE YOU A QUICK PICTURE.
OKAY?
30 SECONDS.
MOGADISHU, SOMALIA, I WAS THERE
IN 2002 WITH MY BROTHER CRAIG,
AND WATCH A YOUNG DOCTOR BLEED
OUT, HE DIED IN FRONT OF US.
HIS HEAD HAD BEEN BLOWN OFF OR
TAKEN AWAY BY AN AR-15.
I SUBMIT TO YOU, LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, THERE IS NO
LEGITIMATE REASON, OTHER THAN
MAYBE SPORT SHOOTING, IF YOU'RE
A REGISTERED PERSON IN ONE OF
THOSE HIGH-END SPORT CLUBS,
THERE'S NO LEGITIMATE REASON TO
HAVE AN AR-15.
YOU CAN'T SHOOT DEER WITH IT.
YOU CAN'T -- IT HAS NO PRACTICAL
SIGNIFICANCE.
WHAT IT DOES, IT MACHOFOR ASS,
IF THAT'S A WORD, THE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE IT, A BIG DEAL.
AR-15s HAVE NO PLACE IN
SOCIETY OTHER THAN SPORTS CLUBS.
I AGREE WITH HIM ON THAT.
IRONICALLY WE DO NEED MORE IRS
AGENTS IF THEY SAY WE NEED MORE
IRS AGENTS.
>> Dana: HE TAKES CREDIT FOR
REDUCING THE DEFICIT, BUT THAT
WAS AFTER THE COVID EMERGENCY
FUNDS WENT DOWN.
WHEN HE SAYS IT'S THE GREATEST
AIRLIFT IN HISTORY.
INCLUDING ON BABY FORMULA.
LIKE HE'S WRITING CHECKS HE
CAN'T CASH, SO TO SPEAK.
>> Brian: A COP NEVER SAYS SHOOT
FOR THE LEG.
IT'S SHOOT FOR THE MASS.
KNOW WHAT YOU DON'T KNOW.
WHEN IT COMES TO SPENDING, HE
SPENT $9.7 TRILLION.
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS GOING TO BE
OVER THE NEXT 10 YEARS.
GOING TO SPEND $6 TRILLION OVER
THE NEXT 10 YEARS.
THIS IS COMING DOWN THE PIKE.
HE WANTS TO REDUCE SPENDING.
HE'S FORTUITOUS IN THIS.
MITCH McCONNELL CAME ACROSS ON
THE DEAL WHEN IT COMES TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
HE CAME ACROSS THE AISLE WHEN IT
CAME TO THE CHIPS BILL,
ORIGINALLY A REPUBLICAN BILL.
HE'S TAKING CREDIT FOR THESE
BILLS THAT THE SENATE CUT A DEAL
WITH, WHICH MOSTLY REPUBLICANS
HAD AGREED WITH.
HE JUST SIGNS IT.
IN FACT, HE ALMOST BLEW IT UP,
BECAUSE HE SAYS I WON'T SIGN ONE
WITHOUT THE OTHER.
THE SCARIEST THING FOR HIS
STAFF, IF THEY'RE PAYING
ATTENTION, WHEN HE WALKS AROUND,
CLEARLY NOT LOOKING AT THE
PROMPTER, BECAUSE YOU HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
BELIEVE ME, HE DOES NOT WANT TO
USE THE WORD "DEMENTED."
IT WAS ONE OF THE WORST WORDS HE
COULD USE.
>> Dana: YEAH.
I WOULDN'T USE THAT WORD.
>> Jeanine: THERE'S NO SOCIAL
REDEEMING VALUE TO AN ASSAULT
WEAPON.
THE CONSTITUTION DOESN'T LIMIT
TO A SOCIALLY REDEEMING FACTOR.
>> Geraldo: THERE WERE NO
ASSAULT WEAPONS THEN.
>> Jeanine: SHOULD WE HAVE
CANNONS IN OUR HOUSE?
LET'S NOT GO THERE.
>> Greg: WHAT DOES AR STAND FOR
ANYWAY?
>> Brian: WE HAVE 607
BILLIONAIRES IN THIS COUNTRY, NO
THE COUNTING GREG, 606, CRACKING
DOWN ON THE BILLIONAIRES, THE
MOST ACCOUNTANTS, MOST OF THEM
PLAYING WITHIN T